this has been an incredible season of
selling sunset but i have to start off
and ask you jason about your
relationship with krishel
when did you go from
colleagues
to a couple and did you have to consult
hr about this well
i am hr i guess
we don't really have like uh i guess we
have
somewhat informal hr but we're kind of a
family so families don't have hr uh in
terms of a timeline i mean it was so it
was kind of fluid for a while
i mean and by the way my recollection of
time is terrible things that happened to
me last week i think were like a year
ago and vice versa um but you know it
was a few months ago
and
yeah certainly
you know we were really good friends for
a long time i don't think either of us
had any
romantic inclinations you know i
it
happened kind of spontaneously and i
think we didn't take it that seriously
um
but
then we started to
you know it was working and we started
taking it really seriously and then kind
of kept it to ourselves for a while
obviously just for privacy reasons
and it just kind of
turned into something really special
that's so nice to hear brett did you
maybe see the beginning of this coming
before jason did
i didn't see it coming until it
it came
i mean you know there was no prelude to
that i didn't i didn't see it until
honestly their first kiss and that's and
obviously i knew it way before everyone
else but i didn't there was really no
inclination that they were ever going to
get together until the day they got
together i don't even think it was
inclination in christelle or jason's
mind yeah there's no way anybody could
have known because we didn't even know
something that we've learned about the
two of you over the seasons is that you
mean business
so with this season we saw you bring in
emma while christine was going on
maternity leave and it was strictly a
business decision in both of your minds
where have things been left off between
the two of them
between emma and christine
correct
i mean i think the audience knows about
as much as we know yeah i mean to be
honest i mean
we
they're still in the same terms as you
would imagine you haven't watched season
four it's not as though there was some
kumbaya movement that you guys missed
yeah i think christelle and christine's
relationship and emma and christine's
relationship is as known by the viewers
as as it is myself and brett in fact
even we
see
things on the show when we finally watch
season four and we'll hopefully soon
watch season five that we didn't know
things that had occurred you know
because we're we're learning when we
watch the show as well because we're not
in all those scenes but i will say that
that the issues with that relationship
are long-standing it wasn't a season
four thing
i've known both of them for a very long
time
they've had some issues prior to selling
sunset the old group was already well
known within the la world
how has your business changed since the
show
you know we people ask us that a lot
it's changed for the better but it
hasn't been some
astronomical exponential you know i
think it
my guess is it would have grown
without the show to almost where it is
today but i think the show is kind of
like that icing on the cake so to speak
and there are we can see direct
correlations between people who have
watched the show and listings that we've
received so i mean it definitely if i
had to put a number on i'd probably say
20
increase but that said we were
increasing you know pretty substantially
every single year um without the show so
it's it's really hard to say but like
again it's it's fun and it's certainly
uh some type of benefit just kind of
hard to quantify and definitely been
beneficial for the um women and
it's been beneficial socially and just
it's just been like jason said just a
lot of fun you know you're going through
it with your brother with your friends
so it's just like a cool experience that
we'll look back on when we're older and
you know remember fondly
the building itself has become a tourist
destination my friends that have been to
la recently will send me photos of them
standing in front of the o group office
does it get annoying at any point having
people standing outside your office well
the wind we tinted the windows so it's
not as bad anymore
sometimes where it's definitely annoying
but sometimes it will pop out for
pictures i shouldn't say that because
we're encouraging people i wouldn't say
it's annoying actually i think it's a
beautiful part of
the publicity is that
you see people so excited and we'll pop
out and take photos with them and like
you know so many of them like tell us it
made their day or their trip and
so i almost feel like you have an
obligation if you're you know putting
yourself in the public sphere to make to
do the small things to make people happy
because it is a privilege um so i
wouldn't say it's annoying i'd say it's
a privilege i would agree with that i
think yesterday a couple days ago i
popped out there
i took pictures with someone from japan
and a woman from belgium and a couple
people from israel and like i don't know
it's just it's it's really a privilege
to use whatever celebrity we have to
make people's days and
10 seconds it's pretty awesome
yeah i'm kind of utilitarian so if i can
spend 10 seconds to make someone happy
then it's almost an obligation what can
you tell us about selling the oc and how
you will be involved
well we are just getting into filming uh
so that'll it'll be a few more months we
actually had the opening party in like a
week yeah
but i mean i could not be more excited
about that show for a couple reasons one
i just love newport beach and the new
office down there which is kind of
awesome
and then it's a really great diverse
group of agents that are many of them
super successful already and just very
dynamic uh
people so it's gonna be interesting i
think the cameras always kind of
exacerbate
things a little bit as they have on
selling sunset so i'm really excited
just to see how and it's also male and
female agents
so you know and some get along and some
don't and you know people are kind of
teaming up and grouping up and
it's such a strong uh
i don't want to say cast because it's
the it's the office but some of you know
most of them are on the cast but yeah i
could not be more excited about that
show yeah it's a good group of people i
think it's going to do really well
dynamic personalities
and we'll see the both incredible
incredible office it's going to be
mostly jason i'm just gonna be popping
it i think he can handle it
i think so
well there's also the other announcement
the selling franchise is just exploding
selling tampa has been announced and you
literally passed off the keys to them
what can fans of selling sunset look
forward to with selling tampa
zero idea because we weren't
we're not involved with that it's just
it's not an opera group brokerage we did
meet the uh the women
recently we had dinner with them they
seemed really cool so we're we're as
much looking forward to seeing that show
and how it is as everybody else and it's
the same producers so and they're
exceptional what they do so i wouldn't
be surprised if it's a great show
you